because I get asked the same questions
many many times in multiple formats not
not just a new tube but also in Facebook
my emails in Google+ and Twitter in
other forums as well I've decided that
when it comes to frequently asked
questions it might be beneficial for me
to start creating some short videos in
which I answer the question and then
discuss why man starting it the way I am
and suggest a few possible things that
the person asking the question might
consider or could do the general type of
question that I have in mind that I'm
responding to here run along these lines
dr. Sandler why don't you shoot some
videos or a video about blank and blank
could be Todd's first critique it could
be work of neech's that I haven't
already discussed it could be some more
Rilke stuff it could be as somebody's
actually suggested while I'm still doing
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit why
don't you also shoot some things at
Hegel's science of logic tip and these
are framed in a number of different ways
sometimes it's hey I you know I like
what you do dr. Sadler I'd like to see
your taken on this or they act sometimes
it's I really have a hard time
understanding this text so I want you to
produce something on it sometimes it's
more like you know it a bit more
challenging how come you haven't produce
something out this or that right so
there's a wide range of questions but
they all boil down to the same basic
format which is in addition to or
instead of what you're already doing or
I've already done why isn't there a
video or a video series on this
now I am going to give you a short
answer and then a longer answer so the
short answer to this request could you
do a video about fill in the blanks and
it's not something that I've already got
planned the short answer is no or yes no
if I'm just being expected to put
everything on hold and jump to whatever
this sort of thing is or somehow put it
into my plans for say the next month or
so yes if you're willing to do the work
required to put up the resources
required to make that happen so that
said let me give you the longer the
answer and I think a lot of this will
make a bit more sense as I go on so I
put out an average of about five videos
per week so that's about 250 videos per
year I've been doing that now for
several years it is not a particularly
remunerative process as a matter of fact
it's actually from a cost-benefit
analysis just based on that sort of
thing a pretty poor you stuff my time
why do I do it and do it in part because
it's a public service and I think that
it's something valuable for me to be
doing and it turns out that I have some
talent for taking complex philosophical
ideas and texts and thinkers and
explaining them in such a way that I'm
not dumping them down I'm making them
accessible you know so it's it's it's
something that I do but it's something
that's quite time-consuming and there's
a lot of investment on my part there's a
lot of time that I spend when I shoot a
video involved in study you know I don't
just get up there and start talking
about some work I reread the work I go
back over it and take notes put things
up on that chalkboard that you see
behind me set up the lighting film you
know sometimes there's problems and I
have to refill things because
too much noise and the ambient
environment I could go on and on and on
the long story short there's a lot
involved in shooting these videos I've
always got a lot more projects underway
than I actually have time for so for
example right at this moment that I'm
shooting this video I'm shooting videos
saying in some core concept videos I'm
shooting videos for an Aristotle class
that I've got currently going on also
core concept videos I'm shooting this
video right now I'm engaged in the
half-hour hagel series and I shoot
videos and places that I'm giving talks
and I give about two to three times per
month so that's that's a lot of
different you know projects a lot of
balls in the air at any given time I
also have to earn some sort of income by
the work that I do if I you know was
able to just produce videos all the time
or say you know eight hours a day I
would probably produce a lot more videos
than I they currently do although I am
Not sure that everyone would watch quite
so many videos getting churned out
constantly
maybe this is a good pace but you know
there's a lot of you know trade-offs and
prioritization that happens with this so
the videos that I'm shooting stuff on
currently those are things that I
consider to be particularly important
and particularly interesting and since
I'm the one who's doing all that work
I'm the one who gets to set that that
agenda I also have some suggestions for
for those who are asking these sorts of
questions or who might you know now if
you're watching this video start
thinking hey I might want to ask that
sort of question as well so my first
thing that I'd like to say is if if it's
really just about finding some sort of
resource on a particular thinker or text
or topic you don't necessarily need it
from me you can go on the interwebs and
start searching around and at least with
certain thinkers you're gonna find quite
a bit with Nietzsche I'm not the only
guy out there shooting
I'm Nietzsche there's actually quite a
few people who have ventured into that
area
same thing with cons I think there's
quite a few people doing work on Conte
there may be some areas where there's
not an awful lot but I think that if you
do some searching you can find something
that will answer to your desires so
that's that's the first point the second
point that I want to say is you know
sometimes I think when people are asking
these questions because it's so easy to
write a comment and just you know shoot
it out right there it could be that
they're just expressing a kind of wish
that that somebody would would do a
video on that they haven't seen it and
they're not actually asking me hey will
you actually do a video on this I'd like
to hold you to this dr. Sadler sometimes
it's that they like my particular
approach and they would like to see me
engaging in that so to the people who
are in that group I would say I can
totally agree with you about the the
need or the desire or the wish to see
video resources available on all sorts
of thinkers and and topics that probably
aren't yet done I'm kind of hoping that
more people will get into this game and
you know I actually do workshops to try
to help other people who are would be
content producers and YouTube academics
and other people to you know get through
some of the learning curve involved with
that so I'm actually in the backend of
that whether you realize it or not
helping to to mentor and guide other
content producers to try to get more
stuff done if you like my approach and
you're asking about the video stuff
specifically because it's you want me to
do videos very flattered thanks for
thinking about me but I might not have
enough time to do all that sort of stuff
for other people who are actively
suggesting that I should set aside time
to produce videos on say
Todd's first fatigue or Schopenhauer's
world as will and representation big
projects like that here's what I have to
say to you if you really want to see
videos like that and you really want me
to do those well then you've got a
couple choices one is you could
Commission me I'm perfectly willing to
set you know some of the projects that
I've got on hold if somebody wants to
pay me the sort of standard rates that
you pay a videographer to produce
content enough if you don't want to do
that well you know YouTube is a free
resource so you kind of get what the
producers want to do another alternative
to that is if you can get enough other
people interested in that sort of thing
you could start a crowdfunding you know
as many different sites out there for
doing that crowdfunding campaign to
support getting dr. Sandler to do what
it is that you'd like him to do I
already do that myself or half of our
Hegel's so I'm not going to start
crowdfunding for something else but if
you want
uncocks first critique and you want it
sooner than later I am willing to do
that if you you know put in the work and
time that may lead some people to say
yeah I'm not really that serious but
that's fine you know but it's a good
thing to think about though the other
thing that I would say is you know you
don't necessarily need videos on a
particular topic if what you're
interested in doing is studying a
particular work and you want to do it
with me I offer one-on-one tutorial
sessions that you can book me for you
don't need me to actually shoot a video
specifically about something unless you
just want to see more videos out there
about this or that so the last thing I'm
going to say after all of that is you
know for those who are asking these
questions you know I'm happy that you
enjoy my work or find it useful or would
like to see more of it but you know this
is a matter of having enough time and
and resources to carry out that's
I'm already like working at full
capacity and perhaps even a little bit
beyond it as it is so giving you these
these suggestions you see where where I
stand on it and hopefully that clears
the matter up entirely if you if you
want to leave comments you can leave
them in the comment section below
don't make them the same if you're going
to answer questions or comments just
don't make it the same one that [ __ ]
about during the video and we'll be
alright so that's all that I had to say
about this particular questions